الموضوع حقيقه
سيذاع مساء هذا اليوم ستضيع هيئه الاذاعه
التلفزيون البريطاني همم طبعا هو يكشف همم
ما جرى همم كواليس الحرب الاوكرانيه وما
جرى اشتياق روسيا في اوكرانيا ايضا رئيس
الوزراء همم احدى مداخلته طبعا الموضوع
همم الموضوع همم حلقات ثلاث ستبدا هذا
اليوم ستركز على كل همم خفايا واسرار هذه
الارض التي جرى برج جونسون في اعترافه في
الحلقه الاولى التي ستذاع مساء هذا اليوم
كما قلت يقول انه همم تم تهديده من قبل
شخصيا حينما قال له لا اريدك وقال له ان
الامر يستغرق همم فقط صاروخا واحدا يعني
بشكل غير مباشر ان الرئيس الروسي قال له
انه يستطيع ان ينال منه ربما بطبيعه
الحياه الحديث الان عن ان يعني هناك
انتقادات كبيره لحزب المحافظين
الحزب سمعه الحزب تنهار ايضا رئيس الوزراء
عليه الكثير من التعاون هناك ايضا ولد
البريطانيين من الوضع الاقتصادي الذي سبته
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ربما ياتي هذا
التصريح حقيقه ضمن تبرير الموقف البريطاني
وموقف موريسون بالتحديد الذي ربما قاد
الحمله الغربيه ضد روسيا وزاره اوكرانيا
اكثر من مره وايضا اعتبر حاله همم نفسه
همم يعني صديق اوكرانيا
الكبير طبعا البرنامج الذي سيعرض سيتحدث
ايضا عن همم
اوكرانيا والرئيس الاوكراني الكواليس الذي
جرت ايضا ما قاله الرئيس فوت حينما سال
مرور جونسون هل اوكرانيا ستدخل حلف
الاطلسي قال له ليس في المدى المنظور قال
له حدد كلمات ماذا تعني بالمدى المنظور
طبعا الخلاف الروسي البريطاني ليس جديدا
هناك صراع قديم ازري حبه كانت هناك فاروق
سابقه بشكل كبير العلاقات تردد واا بشكل
كبير ايضا اكبر حينما سمت روسيا المعارض
الروسي سكريبال ال في في بريطانيا ايضا
همم روسيا كانت تخرق الاجواء البريطانيه
بين الحين والاخر من ناحيه وهذا كان مسار
غضب من همم البريطانيين اذن هذه همم
كواليس ما جرى
من خطاب او من اطول خطاب لنقل اطول لقاء
عبر الهاتف بين رئيس الوزراء السابق برج
جونسون سيعرض هذا المساء وايضا في حلقتين
ستبونين في وقت لاحق هذا